good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday it is
hump
day so make sure to hump someone you
love i've already gotten started this
morning with my son who's looking so
sexy this morning
theo hey hey doo doo doo
so good to see you you look so beautiful
stunning and smart oh
theo is just like everything he's just
what you need to
like power through your week you know it
is like just
it is are you referring to theo isn't it
no that
it's just what you need oh okay because
he's just what you need and so therefore
you
that sentiment is just what you need
sure sure i just wanted to make sure you
know we weren't
um you know going down that road but why
would i ever do that
and have you ever known me to do that no
that's why i was so out of character for
you i just had to call you on it
right but you were wrong jacques jacques
hope everyone had an amazing day
yesterday it's been 24 hours since we
last saw you not that much has happened
we have a good amount of stuff to
discuss the bachelorette was on last
night yes
it is wednesday which means our deer
toasters it's just like
you know it's so in demand everyone
wants to know like wednesday next year
toasters wins the next year
it's always wednesday it's today you
guys so if you ever want to write in the
email is dear toasters gmail.com
we will read your advice completely
anonymously on air and give our you know
we'll try our best
we will we we give good advice feels
like a while since we've done into your
toasters so i have some
fresh advice being cooked up i do
yeah i mean yesterday was a crazy day
spotify wrapped came out and i know
we were just talking about it too it's
such a great day when it's about
december 1st i guess no i know but then
it's like it's really not a 2020 it's
an 11 month yes and then my question is
does the music you listen to in december
count towards
anything like could i just start
listening to crazy stuff just because
because the count doesn't start till
january 1st and like no one's looking
right now no that's such an excellent
question
i i don't know i definitely don't think
it goes into your 20 20
um that wouldn't make sense because it's
not in 2021 i don't know
i would need some some follow-up from
the spotify team
if they did go into the 2020 i would
have more christmas music in my spotify
wrapped in
2021 yeah 2021 because i listen to the
christmas music in december
right i don't have any christmas songs
in my top 100.
maybe that's why they don't include
december in their wrapped because it's
like skewed
influenced by the holiday right yeah but
it is interesting also i feel like they
usually give you a nice thing maybe this
came in my email and i missed it where
it's like
you got an email no they usually send
you an email like letting you know your
wrapped is here
did you get it well it goes to my
college email which i don't check
but i should check it because usually
they send in your email like what you
were listening to in the fall
in the spring right and i do like the
data broken down in that way as well
i just find it such a premium experience
like to go find your data and then like
the little stories they put together
with the music playing in the background
bright colors it's a really premium
experience it's so premium we
actually have a story about spotify rap
so we'll share our insights then
but i just want to say everyone was
tagging us in the minutes they listened
to the toast and like i was posting so
many of them on my stories even though i
know it's like annoying for them it's
like a classic annoying thing like on
social media it was just like
so proud proud and also grateful to
everyone who listens to the show for
thousands of hours who listens to
hundreds of episodes like
this year has been just extremely trying
and i feel like for a lot of you and for
us too like the toast has been the
constant
like a life raft a little bit and i'm
just like
really grateful for to everyone who's
listened this year yeah so we're just
being annoying like showing everyone we
have so many listeners you know like
i wish i could post all of the mention
yeah i know but now i just started
posting like the ones that are like
hundreds of episodes no it's actually
crazy just seeing how much um
how many episodes people listen to a
year because we have had
204 new episodes this year but some
people have watched like over 400
episodes because they're listening to
old episodes 204
our um on podcast yeah no our
back end oh interesting that's without
patreon
i saw that too but it's 204. oh wow we
do so many episodes it's insane
i know it but then some people are
posting i post i listen to 180 episodes
i'm like well you missed 20.
yeah no no i was thinking i'm like 180
that's not enough you haven't listened
to all of that well then i was also
thinking okay so we're up to 204
episodes we probably have like
15 more episodes maybe no no maybe less
this year
but there's 365 days in a year now of
course you have to take out
weekends holidays and vacations so it's
just like how many week
days are there in a year i mean
we could here i'll do it quickly so
there's 52 weeks in a year means that
there's 55
52 weekends oh sure 104 weekends so
365 minus 104 is 261.
oh and we did we'll end up doing like 2
15 220. i think that's pretty good
yeah plus like established holidays
and then like when we were away in
august we did one episode a week and
plus patreon
plus patreon probably brings us back to
like two probably brings us around 250.
so there's probably
hypothetically a episode of the morning
toast for every weekday
of the year probably that's our
intention because if we're not here
we're doing patreon and we're always
just giving like content in random
places
yeah it's also a leap year so we had
that extra day for you
yeah yeah yeah yeah i forgot it was a
leap year so much happened i know and
the leap
day was uh before all this corona virus
like drama we got one more good day in
though that's
true gotta count your blessings oh my
god i'm so grateful you know i feel
really um you know i don't really know a
lot of stuff
like about science or history or
geography
or biology or pretty much any theologies
but i feel really like um you know when
it's like you know one weird piece of
trivia and like you just
you bring it up whenever you can to
every piece of conversation i like
understand why we have leap years and
it's like what because i i learned it in
school once and i just never forgot it
it's like weird what sticks with you
and i feel so proud do you to do you
know what i think people would want to
know why sometimes we do like to educate
and inform here so do you know that
every year is how many days 365 claudia
wrong
it's actually 365 and six hours okay
so every four years those extra six
hours accumulate in
one extra day and that's what leap day
february 29th
right february 29th yeah i believe we
were in la the la steens
you want to know how i know that because
i just got my spotify wrapped my number
one song of the year
i'm going to spoil this even though we
do have a story about just spotify rapt
in general my number one song of the
year was stupid love by lady gaga
they said the first time that i played
it was february 28th and it came out
while we were in l.a remember we were
like
listening and can you believe and if you
listen to my reaction because i think we
talked about on the toast
my reaction to that song i was like it's
good whatever number one song of the
year for me
i mean i also just can't believe we
traveled
um like a week before coronavirus
yeah and then i was also in miami for
presidents day weekend so like that was
before that
oh it was yeah so like it was just like
now that we've
it's december so like pardon me for just
getting like emotional like perspective
you know like
it's just so crazy like when you take a
step back and realize how like we were
moving so fast like even like the week
before chronovirus like
we would not be stopped like not we you
and i we as a society like we as a
society everything was just still
happening and then one day like the
world just
paused and it and it never never turned
back on again
that's why please
um so yeah sorry to get all
introspective but
i feel like this is the month and it's
december 2nd so we're starting early
but like where and even in the stories
today you'll see like everything is now
like year end
roundup like we have like people
apparently has their people of the year
everything is of the year we got spotify
rap like yeah we're and i feel like
we're gonna be doing a lot of episodes
that are like our best of the year even
the redheads oh i need to make this
announcement because i only announced it
on instagram live
such a big deal you guys maybe just take
a second if you're listening to this
podcast
sit down and just brace yourselves for
what's about to come maybe
made your name maybe you take a second
and stop being so mean to the redheads
who are going to be like
it's a really big deal it's not a really
big deal
but it's a big deal the redheads episode
this week is dropping one week later
because of scheduling conflicts we
wanted to be able to record
in person make it the best episode
possible because we're going to do our
whole year in review and the book that
we read this month is
it so it will drop next thursday not
tomorrow i'm sorry
if this like ruins anything for you i
told you guys you were going to want to
sit down
i was right i wasn't being dramatic i'm
being dead serious okay can just like
throw a wrench people's plans and not
make it a big deal
i know and i only had to announce it on
like the instagram live which i feel
like
millions of people watch but it was only
millions billions it was only a handful
so
so now you know um but yes i agree with
you i think something about like
it now being december this whole year
we've been like i can't believe it's
already the summer
but now that it's actually december
december hit different
for everyone and i think everyone's
becoming like deeply
um introspective and like nostalgic over
the year
nostalgic for the good two months yeah
so i think just putting
the fact that it's december like really
puts into perspective like the year is
over i know that's obvious seeing us how
december is the last month
but like it just makes you like emo and
stuff yes it definitely does and it's
usually more fun to reflect
on the year in december because there is
like so much to reflect on
this year is obviously different but i
feel like we'll still have some things
to reflect on like different phases of
quarantine like remember the tie-dye
phase
yeah that was a dark time there was
tiger king phase
tiger king phase i remember the um for
me the knitting phase
that was that was a low point for sure
there was like a chips phase
where i was eating chips every day that
sounds like an awesome face yeah and
then i was
i graduated to french fries oh for me
there was like the taco phase where like
literally all i ate was tacos there was
like passover there that's how i started
eating chips passover i can't believe we
had passover and zuma
yeah that was so sad that was the zoomed
toast phase zoom toast
phase there was there was some dark
times i could bring up some bad stuff
too but i'm just looking to move forward
keep my head towards 2021 2021 we're
right on track
so speaking of moving forward let's get
in oh my god you're like the nerd who
drops all of this
i have so many cards today because we
have obviously the sponsors but then we
also have dear toaster so i'm like
oh no i can't keep my cards up
sorry so unprofessional of me
are you like the nerd no i'm like i get
shoved into a locker i'm like oh oh my
god
my textbook okay let's go
when i'm ready let's go i don't
i'm not feeling it are you
what are you saying okay now it's time
to dive into the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
don't hit that crunch yeah that's right
you don't do it you're not the only one
who could do it jackie
okay and today's episode is brought to
you by hush blankets
which has really been the true sponsor
of quarantine mine the one that we got
um
i don't know maybe i've had it for like
eight months now still at the edge of my
bed it's the best thing that i own and
i'm literally i've convinced all my
friends to get it
it is the best most high quality
weighted blanket out there
i was um i always do what the weighted
blanket was for me i just
saw some that were like kind of ugly and
the hush blankets one are really
really cute i have like a navy blue
velvet one it's the throw blanket and
they're just way more stylized because
i've seen some really ugly ones so while
i believe in the power of weighted blank
it's like i just don't want something
ugly on my bed
no but the hush blankets one are stylish
as hell and the navy blue one matches
your navy blue pillows
yes it does um the quality of the
blanket is fabulous it is made with
luxurious high quality materials
the hush blanket is substantially better
better looking than any other weighted
blanket on the market i completely agree
and if you want to know the benefits of
a weighted blanket and why it might be
helpful for you
um in these stressful times especially
with with what's going on in the world
people are experiencing stress and
anxiety about many things and the hush
blanket goal is to provide
a sense of relief the hush blanket will
help you relax
stay calm and feel like a big hug it's
actually proven to help have a deeper
sleep
you can actually be proven to stay
asleep longer and it's proven to help
people who experience anxiety and stress
and the hush blanket give back program
it's fabulous because they donate one in
one in ten adult blankets and one in
five kids blankets to charities and
shelters in need it's been a huge part
of their brand since day one
and they also have 100 night guarantees
so if you're on the fence about it the
return and exchange process is super
easy you have 100 nights to test out
your blanket and if you don't love it
you'll see you can send it back to them
for a full refund no questions asked
i don't think that's going to happen but
it's nice to have that sort of security
blanket um if you also if you feel like
it's too heavy or light you can exchange
sizes so it's not just like one size but
it's always like different people need
different weights you know um if you
want to check out hush blankets and also
get a 15
off code use the code toaster that's
e r t-o-a-s-t-e-r hush blankets dot com
but only
um if you use hushblankets.com promo
code toaster t-o-a-s-t-e-r
for fifteen percent off and then it goes
down to ten percent off so make sure you
use it
asap hushblankets.com love it
okay um i was gonna say something about
houseplant kids oh i just feel like i'm
really feeling blankets right now like
it's
blanket season vibe cultivated
cultivation is so
premium and you need a blanket in order
to achieve the cultivated vibes and also
blankets are an amazing gift
yes i agree it's so cozy and personal in
these times especially
yes okay first story big news of the day
ellen page comes out as transgender
will be called elliott ellen page is
transgender and will now go by by the
name elliot page he announced on social
media on tuesday
quote i feel lucky to be writing this to
be here to have arrived at this place in
my life he wrote
i feel overwhelmingly gratitude for the
incredible people who have supported me
along this journey
i can't begin to express how remarkable
it feels to finally love who i am
enough to pursue my authentic self paige
said he will use
he they pronouns got it um i thought
that
the statement posted on his social media
was like very profound and very well
said
and um i i mean this is just wonderful i
feel like this is a big deal i feel like
there aren't
tons of celebrities i can only think of
two
who who are who have come out as
transgender after being
famous after being famous yes yes yes um
and that's
caitlyn jenner and chaz bono yeah
yeah chesmar yeah for sure no it's it's
so great it's always nice to see someone
who's just like being their
true complete self and i think that's
the greatest feeling for anyone
totally i think some people have you
know a tougher road getting there
but i just always find it so inspiring
like because that's just
the motto be yourself yeah and it's like
it's so much easier said than done but
like when you right when you literally
live your life feeling you were feeling
like you were born in the wrong body
like that's such a big change
and i agree like living seeing people
who just like do them and like
unapologetically like i'm so jealous of
that you know yeah
so i'm happy for him very happy so
beautiful so many celebs are coming out
to support
sarah james gunn miley cyrus anna paquin
also he is in umbrella academy which i
haven't heard of
i've heard of it and i think i've heard
that it's really good but i've never
watched i was just curious if you've
seen it
no i have not seen it but like people
keep recommending new netflix shows to
me and like
i i'm actually feeling like my plate
might be like on the verge of getting
full even though i'm like so
in you have a big plate even though i'm
like so invested and lost right now and
i found out something crazy about lost
okay so there's a character he's like a
young kid his name is walt he's like a
cutie and he's like he's important
and obviously the show was like 10 years
ago and you know who walt is now
he's one half of mk mk and kto yes
i'm like having a stroke today
when i was born in the wrong time you're
one of a kind living in a world going on
baby you're so classic so does that have
no business going that hard yes 100
and i just found out he's one half of
mkto i
love that for him that's a really happy
ending so that's my
um dilemma now yes i've heard umbrella
academy is very good i've heard it in
the dark is very good i'm like missing
out on
some netflix shows never heard of in the
dark you should also watch money heist
so good is it a story um about millie
bobby brown
no so could we just talk about it really
quickly did you see the video she posted
on social media
no um she was like did a series of
instagram stories like crying about this
experience she had in the mall where
like some girl
asked if she could if like she's like
are you emily bobby brown and millie
bobby brown was like yeah and the girl
was like can i take a video of you
and millie bobby brown was like like a
video of me just like standing here
and the girl was like yeah millie bobby
brown was like no and then the girl like
continued to like invade millie
bobby brown's personal space and um
like video her and her mom she was
shopping at the mall with her mom for
holiday season
and it was like kind of like really sad
like like i think on the surface and i
was reading people's
like feedback from it it's like people
didn't see what the big deal was like
it was like one girl but i like totally
um like fell from really bad around
she's like 11 years old you know
yeah i mean she is getting older so i
don't think she's loving anything no i
know but she will
always be 11 to me do you yeah no i do
know what you mean i think that is weird
like if
i'm sure if she had asked for a selfie
i'm sure millie would have 100
said yes and that's what she said in the
video she's like i'll take a picture
with anyone but that's just weird
yeah that's a weird request yeah no it
is right like why do you want a video of
millie bobby like and it's not like she
said can you say hi to my sister wish my
mom happy birthday like
she literally just said i can't video
you yeah that is weird but it's become
such a big story and all i kept thinking
about last night like is
what is that girl thinking like she's
like probably like in her home and like
locked herself in her bedroom and she's
like freaking out how she like made
millie bobby brown cry
good that's good it's a learning thing
no for sure it was a lesson that needs
to be learned
but at the end of the day she's just
like a fan and she was probably like a
nice girl
millie baby brown didn't like share her
name or no but i'm sure this girl just
has like the biggest picture right
right but she's learning a lesson yeah
of course of course and it's important
to go and ruin someone else's day now
it's important to learn your lessons for
sure but she's probably just like
freaking out she's like
i don't know how old she is but i'm just
the way i picture it she's a kid
yeah well you know kids supporting other
kids always always always yeah
no i'd love to see a lesson learned
lessons being learned
okay we have some hosting news are you
ready for it oh
yes i know the talk yes the talk names
amanda klutz and elaine
weltroth as co-hosts the talk named two
co-hosts on wednesday
after page six exclusively revealed that
producers and network execs
have been panicking over ratings so
first celebrity trainer amanda cloots
who lost her husband broadway star nick
cordero to coven 19 earlier this year
and journalist elaine weltroth are
joining the upcoming 11th season when it
premieres on january 4th
2021 the show announced who are the
other they'll join returning hosts
sharon osborne cheryl underwood and
carriana namba
yeah i just found out that carrie annan
abba was on is she on cbs
what channel is this the talk is that
cbs that's
yes the cbs insider okay i have to say
something you know i i find hosting news
to be very interesting like i think what
goes on at the view
is very interesting i think the real is
actually an amazing show
um i'm always keeping up with hosting
news and i have literally never in my
life seen
one minute of the talk i literally did
not even know this was a show
um they obviously have a problem with
like brand imaging because i've never
heard of it and yeah but i haven't like
i
i couldn't tell you who was on it but
now like remembering that like sharon
osbourne is on a talk show it sounds
familiar
and marie osmond who just left okay i
hear that but i'm like the view
the real the talk it's just like i don't
i don't know her do you know what i mean
no i do know what you mean
it's definitely the view the real the
what right yeah
like um this is and so i'm glad that
they're making waves with their hosting
announcement and like that people are
talking about it maybe
people will tune in like i just and by
the way we're not alone because
sources recently told page six that the
show's big bigwigs were quote
panicking after the talks ratings
dropped to 1.5 million
half of the views audience so like they
are you know that
that third what yeah and they know it
you know what they are
and the numbers show it you know what
they are what morning glory
yes what was that show called um day
break day break like that losery show
with like no ratings who were just like
trying to do their best but maybe but on
a legit network but maybe
literally like cbs it was called like ib
ibs ibs irritable balancing yeah
ibm is a tech company if you haven't
seen the movie the morning morning
morning glory like you just have to
you just have to but so maybe they got a
new big wig in there in the form of
rachel mcadams well they brought in
harrison ford
and that's not what they're doing here
they're going like more new media
which they should and i actually think
amanda klutz is a great um
choice for them like she's very
digitally savvy she's young she's fresh
um who was the other one announced
elaine weltroth
she's great too she was on project
runway uh she's been the editor-in-chief
of teen vogue i think or
yeah um these are actually two really
like whoever chose these whatever new
big wig was put in charge of this
particular wig
um it did a good job because these are
two actually like very
good choices that could that give this
show a chance yeah
a chance yeah yeah like it's not
confirmed it's gonna be a hit now
yeah i actually think what's so great
about the view is like obviously i think
it's like one of the
few places on tv that's like um like
open dialogue like
people from all walks of like the
political spectrum but it's also like
young and old like megan mccain i think
is the youngest one on there and like
she lives and has totally different
perspectives
of like what's going on than like joy
beijer and whippy goldberg so i actually
think it's cool and they're probably
mimicking that
to have like someone super young like
elaine welteroff and then like sharon
osbourne like two totally different
walks of life
yes but then it's like will they
mix and well like you know it's sort of
that magic that you can't put your
finger on do they have it or do they not
right and then we'll find out on january
4th on cbs and that's why the view is so
successful because
it's like they fight like crazy but like
i think they've all known each other
like for so long even before the view so
there's like that mutual love and
respect that i don't think they actually
like
you can you watch and you're like oh my
god these people hate each other but
they don't but i think that there have
been instances where they truly
do and there's that ladies who punch you
know there was a dark time
there was a dark time on the view i
think that you should read yeah i think
i should
that was was that the elizabeth
hasselbach era it's like the whole era
and the barbara walters it's like a
history of the view
that actually sounds interesting yeah
okay maybe i'll read that that's a good
um
after i finish the invisible life of
addie larue by v.e schwab the new
redheads book which is
so good it's like so well written in
like it
you know yeah um i'm really looking
forward to your january selects
yeah they should be interesting i don't
know what we're gonna pick yet oh i
think i know what you're gonna pick
girl with no job the crazy beautiful
life of an instagram thirst monster my
book comes out january 26 2021.
you know that really feels like it so
far but it's not so far anymore so no
it's not head over to girlwithnowjob.com
book or just head over to my instagram
girl within a job tap the link in my bio
you could shop my book at tons of places
obviously amazon barnes and noble the
classic places but you can also support
local bookstores using
bookshop.com or indiebound and all the
resources are on my instagram and i
would just really appreciate
if you could pre-order it because
that'll help me get into airports and i
really want to be in airports because i
just feel like
famous people are in airports like if
you're not in an airport go home
yeah okay you ready for our next story
always people
oh wait no is it the next story that's
brought to you by usual wines
yes it is perfect pairings well this is
perfect
wine from usual wines i love my usual
do it are we sweating is a great one
it's easy
they're um fabulous brands they're like
an amazing brand that's for you to get
started
a genius concept that anyone could have
thought of but they did and they're
doing it better than anyone really
usual wines are wines for the modern
drinker that's us each bottle is 6.3
ounces
a heavy pour or about a glass and a half
of wine i love a glass and a half
by the way restaurants that do that are
living in the year 3000. no 100
that's usu that's always what i drink a
glass and a half now i know six point
three ounces or the size of it usually
so you're gonna walk into restaurants be
like hi may have 6.3 ounces please
literally no more pouring wine down the
sink when you don't want to finish the
bottle because of the single serve
format and bottle design
usual is always fresh no more flat
bubbly or stale
rose i can't deal with stale
wine i just can't it's so sick and like
you know you're desperate when it's
absorbed all the smells of your fridge
no you're literally drinking garlic wine
it's sick
this is fine the wines are low carb and
have zero grams of sugar that's so
important because as someone who's
normally usually doing keto and wine is
my drink of choice
it some minds do have a little bit of
carbs but now with usual wines you don't
have to make that hard choice
usual has a red blend a rose and a
sparkling white wine called brut
they also have a lemonade i literally
can't say the word brute either without
saying brute
ben's deodorant is brand and like ben
are you out of brute i'm going to the
store
they have a limited production brut rose
just for the summer
usual wines are made from world-class
ava's that's the american vita cultural
area
in california like napa sonoma and santa
barbara
and are made with minimal intervention
zero sugar and zero additives
but grapes don't
okay give it back no no no i feel like
more of a rose yeah if you love fruit
wines as much as i do
try usual wines it's 6.3 ounces per
glass okay but here's the tea okay
here's the wine
here's the grape we have a special
holiday product coming early november
called the usual reserve
it's an ultra premium limited edition
mount vitor cabernet sauvignon
introducing usual reserve this is our
most special wine yet
just in time for the holidays hailing
from one of the most celebrated plots of
land in all of napa
the cabernet sauvignon is concentrated
and rich with just enough grip
give it to someone gift it to someone
special or keep it all for yourself this
is a gift for olivia like 100
100 the holidays as usual now here is
the actual
meat and potatoes go check out their
website at www.usualwines.com
use our discount code toast for eight
dollars off your first order and try
your first class
on us you're welcome happy holidays
usual wines dot com code toast
are you gonna sneeze on that on that
truth bomb excuse me also
not i know it's not a fast five story
but um really quickly i wanted to talk
about
i don't know if you guys heard but our
niece michaela tried solid food today
for the first time
and it's just such a big deal it's such
a big deal like
she is just making leaps and bounds no
she's a medical marvel
and she's literally gonna be like the
world's greatest scientist because she's
a genius
no totally like she was just chomping on
this like breast milk oat milk
oatmeal so stunning and it was stunning
and i just
it's big news so i just want to share
yeah and everyone's talking about it and
we just always give you the news that
you need to know and that's definitely
something you needed to know we would be
not doing our job if we didn't share
that right
okay next up people apparently has your
people of the year
and they're revealing who those people
and this is different from like their
most beautiful man most beautiful most
sexy yeah this is different these are
just like
people good people okay according to
people okay
george oh i see what they did there no
no i did that yeah but i'm sure
they did it too i guess
i guess i don't know like what else
would they do you know
no i know but like like person celeb of
the year prison of the year like
i'm sure they literally intentionally
use the word people well they introduce
their 20 20 people of the year we have
george clooney regina king dr anthony
fauci
and selena gomez without delicious
definitions make the boys go loco
no vouchalicious definitious makes the
ducks go loco
um anyway so it's like a nice group of
people yeah selena gomez is on the cover
and i guess like it really was a good
year for selena gomez because she
launched her beauty line
aside from the drama with saved by the
bell which i'm sure she literally
doesn't even care about
right um yeah she launched rare beauty
which i believe was like a smash success
i saw really positive reviews
for like and i went to she did collabs
with like certain youtubers so obviously
they said like the products were like
heavenly but i also went to like people
who would normally like
rate makeup like completely honestly and
apart from her
her sponge which was pretty much
regarded as like terrible everyone
loved everything in the brand so i
haven't tried anything but i've been
meaning to try the eyeliner yeah no i
think she had like a great
launch i think the brand is well on its
way she also put out a number one album
oh i forgot yeah and became a successful
cooking show host with her hbo max
series selena and chef
i feel like this is like the most she's
done in a while yeah no so it was a big
year for her
year ago people of the year yeah i don't
know like if i was
you know well i guess i am a working
person but like would i want
2020 to be like the year that i did the
most i don't know
i think any year that's going to be a
good yeah i think for sure
i don't know who would be your people of
the year like my person who i feel like
accomplished the most in terms of
business or like
either because there's a there's a bunch
of people that run the gamut here you
know
i would say like any public figure who
didn't find themselves like wrapped up
in some sort of controversy
this year um is doing the most and and
is in the clear
and is winning because it was really a
terrible year to be
a public figure or someone with like an
instagram following yeah
okay so no one specifically i i can't
think of any honestly gigi hadid had a
great year like she had a full-blown
baby and like
is so famous like people are just like
dying literally she posts a picture of
her kids like hair they're like
look at gigi's daughter like people are
obsessed so i think gigi and zayn had a
good year
okay um do you have someone i think
doctor theodore faceman had a good year
yeah he just i mean it did get kind of
competitive between him and dr fauci
at certain points of the year because he
was dr facchi and dr fauci yeah
which is you know it was it got heated
it did get heated but he always has a
good year
always like they could save him for next
year do you ever like think about people
whose lives you want to switch with
uh not in those exact terms but lives of
which i am
green with envy rachel yeah so rachel
parcell and
joe marcel had a good year amazing i
just don't think rachel marcel has ever
had a bad year
i know you don't know what goes on
behind closed doors but i know for sure
she has never had a bad year so i've
been thinking actually um
recently i always think like i wish i
was theo like his life is just so
stress-free it must be frustrating not
to be able to communicate
but also i don't think he has like the
emotional intelligence to know like what
communicating is you know what i mean
um but then i've also really been
thinking about how like i'm green with
envy over olivia's life like
she and her husband are just like so
happy they never leave their house their
baby's so [ __ ] cute
they like drink wine when the baby's
asleep and they just like cook fabulous
meals and
i've been thinking like i want her life
yeah i would also put up miss kaler for
people of the year 100 actually i'm
offended it's disgusting that it took us
this long
no that they shouldn't even get an
honorable mention from people's
magazines sick
sick taylor just was really like i
realized that babies exist
outside of kayla i fully accept that um
and that
what kaler does for us other babies do
for other people but i just don't think
anyone does it better
no i i i have a hard time believing i
believe that everyone believes that
about their own
kin yeah and i think that's so wonderful
i'm so happy for everyone who feels that
way that we feel towards kayla you know
it's an amazing feeling and i know i'm
not unique in it but i like to think
that i am
yeah no that's nice thanks um okay ready
for our next story a little chores and
like the streaming wars
sure sure discovery is going to
launch a streaming service in january at
4.99 per month discovery verizon
customers get a year free and that is us
discovery hgtv gtv shark week
food network you know the fam magnolia i
think they bought own right
oprah winfrey network yeah okay i mean
i don't know who needs this and and i'm
a big hgtv
i feel like discovery should have
partnered with an existing streaming
service like
this is just on another level this is
really niche
yeah but maybe this is the future
instead of everyone having chat
right every channel is a streaming
service and then you just go to the
different apps in your
in your roku instead of different
channels on your cable
that's a very interesting observation
and something i could definitely see
because i don't see a need for this and
i'm someone who really likes hg hgtv
but like watching it on cable is like
more than enough for me like or i have
the
hgtv app where they have like loads of
content are they going to get rid of
that
i'm sure they'll do some sort of merge
yeah you know sort of how like hbo go
and hpm max just became one
yeah that was confusing but i have to
say like i'm actually really liking hbo
max it's one of my favorite it's like a
really uh
a front runner in this streaming war so
far like the streaming wars
everyone's really stepped it up disney
plus is everything of the source
who has yet to really like fix their
problems hulu hulu
yeah and their paws and then the show
starts over
where you are they don't know what how
many episodes you've watched
you know and it's a shame by the way
because they actually have i would say
maybe
top two in all the streaming platforms
the best catalog of content like
desperate housewives is on there
i'm watching lost on there like they
have the most mad men was on there like
they have the most random stuff you know
mad men was prime sorry
yeah and i think i watched mad men on
netflix when it was on also
the thing about who oh what i was going
to say is a streaming service that had a
really good like pause play
remembrance memory was acorn where i
watched a place to call home
one of the highlights of my year i need
to keep that in the back of my mind for
when we do like recap
i need your help so i started a place to
call home and i just like never really
got into it but i had to pay 7.99 a
month
i cannot figure out how to cancel it
literally i go to the website they're
like oh you you signed up on your tv you
have to cancel on your tv
go to my tv they say oh you signed up on
your computer you have to cancel on your
computer
they're swindling me i'm about to just
cancel my whole [ __ ] credit card like
just to get
this 799. it's killing me like i did the
week free trial and
i knew i remembered to cancel it before
the trial was up but they are swindling
me
understood well i think that it's just a
sign that you should watch the show no
my plate is people and i never really
liked it maybe they know that you
haven't given it a fair shot yet
i feel like six episodes is fair shot oh
you really didn't like it
i did not like it it just didn't like i
didn't wake up and be like what's going
on in
inverness vanessa today inverness oh in
inverness
what's going on inverness or in
inverness in inverness
got it okay yeah no i just i didn't i
didn't connect with it
okay fine not for everyone fifth and
final story ready for it always
a little data news from spotify amongst
all the other data they're giving us
they're letting us know that the most
streamed artist
on spotify for 2020 was let me guess
i don't know if you're gonna get billy
eilish no
maluma no bad bunny bad bunny yeah
the puerto rican superstar is the music
platform's most streamed artist of the
year with 8.3
billion streams globally the latin
grammy winner and hitmaker who released
a new album last week leads a top five
list that also includes
drake j balvin juice world and the
weekend
that's crazy that's not who i would
expect no that's not who i would expect
either that's that's an interesting top
five
yeah um i also watched the billy eyeless
totally random i watched her vanity fair
thing last night
the same interview yeah it was kind of
like kind of long and annoying to watch
i just wanted to see her 2021 like i've
seen the other ones i don't need to like
keep rewatching them it was kind of
frustratingly
edited oh you know i've never watched
one of them but
um i like the concept i like seeing her
hair change um
each year like that's cool 2019 to 2020
did not change yeah
yeah that's interesting anyway so that's
just an interesting piece of information
um congratulations to bad bunny on the
amazing year
now i want to hear what's in your
spotify wrapped well mine was actually
really shocking because
um like i always knew i was like a big
lauren elena fan but i guess i didn't
realize like how big of a fan i was
because
my number one song was getting good like
that's the song i listen to the most
times this year
wow such a good song what was yours my
number one song was stupid love by lady
gaga okay
number two song even though i'm leaving
by luke combs
this bar by morgan wallin wow i found
myself in
this bar making mistakes to and making
new friends
number three i was growing up when
nothing made sense
i listened to it what a hundred times i
still don't know in other words i found
myself in this box number three
physical dual ipa stunning song before
you go lewis capaldi
interesting number four hollywood louis
capaldi
mine is invisible string by taylor swift
which i find really interesting because
that's definitely number one song from
folklore for you then but it's not but
it is more than piece apparently
but i feel like it might just be like
when i but the thing is with folklore
and mostly taylor swift i always buy her
albums because i know like she's a big
purveyor of like artists owning their
own
work or whatever so i actually listen to
most of my taylor on apple music because
i own reputation i own folklore i own
lover
so i feel like my taylor swift data is
actually not accurate on spotify
even though she was my number one artist
and they said i was within like one
percent of
you know her top listenership i feel
like i was actually more because i
listened to more of it on
you know i was in her top two percent of
listenership that's crazy and you know
olivia who's like always like hating on
taylor swift just because olivia's like
you know she's like they're off the
beaten path they're just like they're
not who was olivia's number one artist
taylor [ __ ] swift well it was
the year of taylor swift what was your
number five song
august by taylor swift which i which
tracks but i just think like
folklore was probably my number four and
five songs for sure but i don't know if
it was definitely august but i feel like
it also would have been better your
piece got it my number five was before
you go by lewis capaldi so i have two
louis i've been telling i've been trying
to tell you guys that i'm really into
lewis capaldi and now spotify just
showed you
two lewis capaldi songs in my top five
what song did you like discover before
it hit 50 000 streams
oh um i didn't take a screenshot of that
mine is
country and made by lauren elena like
i'm literally lauren elena's number one
fan that's so funny and then
who are your top artists taylor swift
number one same
wow number two lady a wow luke combs for
me
because i made a playlist called um lady
a of all of my favorite songs pretty
much all of their songs
minus like five or six that i can't
stand where i would just listen to it on
shuffle and i did the same thing for my
number three artist rascal flatts and
it's also because i thought they were
retiring and that we were going to go on
tour and follow them and like do molly
every night and then that didn't happen
my number three was five seconds of
summer um which i really loved like
i know like the data is um like
statistical so it's like so
me but it really is like so me you know
yeah my number four was also rascal
flatts my number four was lady gaga
and then my number five was queen lauren
elena my number five is luke combs
i just really i just feel like really
represented by like these top artists
like i
i do obviously like i wish like morgan
mall were in there and
you know some other artists that i loved
um but i do feel like this is an
accurate representation of me
but that's because yeah i also thought
really interesting was my top genres and
i feel like they were definitely skewed
because of folklore
because my number one pop genre was pop
and
i definitely do not listen to pop the
most i listen to contemporary country
which was my number two which is right
behind like us
but it must have been because folklore
pushed it over the edge and just
probably my general love for taylor
swift pushed it over the edge
and then also my number three was
christian music
oh that's so interesting my number three
was christian music also my number two
was contemporary country and my number
one
was pop i don't know if like people find
other people's i feel like
talking about your stats is like talking
about your dreams like nobody cares i
know
okay and i feel that way too i'm just
like so interested in it that i can't
help but
share it and also like we do talk a lot
about the show like about pop culture
and so
it's interesting to hear what we
actually listen to like i feel like we
talked about like so many albums like
ari has an album coming out apparently i
didn't listen to it yeah you know no i
definitely
agree with that these are the things
that track our data is you know
further proof of our stanhood to
literally everything we talk about here
right it's not like go home and like
listen to bach
and then come here i actually do dabble
in beethoven and i
come here and pretend to be like a pop
queen yeah no i agree with you like this
is just proof that we we do our homework
no that like we're yeah we're here for a
reason
yeah um okay well those were the first
five stories you needed to know them
and speaking of things you didn't need
to know let's talk about last night's
bachelorette let's talk about it
um it was really like a an episode for
me where
i feel like up until now i've really
been feeling like all these guys like i
love them and now they're like
all individually starting to annoy me oh
interesting there's like
two or three people who i came into the
season like feeling really strong
towards and now i'm like
out on them well margo the snatcher
posted
probably the most um profound tweet
about bennett that i couldn't agree more
with and it's it's that quote and every
time i hear this quote
it shakes me to my core you told me
about it and you said ariana on
vanderpump rule said it to sheena to
sheena um but it's actually a
direct quote when ben made me watch
batman over quarantine it's from batman
and it's obviously uh you either die the
hero or live long enough to become the
villain and that is bennett 2
80 literally i thought he was so funny
even like even up until like last week
the week before like when he was being
like mean i thought i still thought it
was funny
now he's gone to a place that is so
[ __ ] annoying like i cannot wait for
him to go home so stupid and the first
person to use the word emotional
intelligence on the bachelor is
out like agreed and i'm out on them and
that that whole emotional intelligence
thing is like it's so played out i mean
when he was describing the four tenets
of emotional intelligence i was kind of
interested
i agree i was listening to a seminar on
on emotional intelligence because i
didn't know that right but like separate
from the episode with a bachelor and i
don't even want to decide whose side i'm
on or like who i think is wrong or right
because at the end of the day
it doesn't matter because if you have
somehow found yourself in this room with
tasha like fighting about drama like
you're not the man for tasha and that's
at the end of the day like that's all
that matters that is all that matters so
let's start from the beginning because
she had a one-on-one with zaxi
and whom i love whom i love the date
itself was like wedding pictures that
like the footage was better than the
photos that were blurry
why did they do that it was so strange
and that was like a terrible promo for
the photographer i know i thought the
same thing every time they snapped the
picture and showed what it turned out
like they literally looked like somebody
put vaseline on the lens
exactly like like iphone portrait mode
would have been better no i was so
confused
so confusing and why do they do dates
like that like such a terrible concept
for a day they did
like make it fun and cute sort of but
like when they were when he was like
this is how it actually feels on your
wedding day it's like
no no no you're just wearing a suit no
but i did
um i was actually really shocked when he
also said he was married briefly at one
point
and any time one of the contestants says
that they're married i'm like [ __ ] yes
like this is the man for you because now
there's two
brendan who i still really like and i
think tasha still really likes
and now zach c and obviously him talking
about his wedding
like opened up this huge floodgate into
like what he went through in the past 10
years in the past 10 years which i
thought was
very inspiring and very honest like
every time you reveal something new
about himself i'm like oh wow that's it
and then he's like literally he just
didn't stop it was like honesty
truth honestly truth like he just opened
up so much and i honestly i don't think
i've ever seen anyone on the show like
be
that honest 100 and like he could have
been more vague about
it but he he just went there and he
really opened up and shared
he didn't hold back and i was very
impressed by his honesty as well i think
tasha was he got the rose and i think
she already really liked him before and
i think they're like you know they have
that
bond now i agree i was just really shook
um
at the sheer honesty of it yeah there's
he's one to watch 100
he's definitely up there like maybe
makes it to hometowns
then we go on the group date which was
the whole art thing and
i like i really don't want to be mean so
i'm really just not going to say
anything okay i don't want to be mean
but i'm going to say something first i
just want to say like i think when
anybody
opens up about like their struggles and
their past
especially on tv but even not on tv in
real life like i think that it is so
brave
i couldn't remember and it's become this
like trope on the bachelor that you're
one-on-one and then you share like
the thing that you went through and i
think we've all become really accustomed
to that and that is really important in
getting to know someone
in a relationship 100 percent i feel
like i have such a better sense of who
zack c is now knowing so much about him
of course than i did before his
one-on-one and having dinner with tasha
in a romantic setting is the perfect
place to open up
i just well it went down on the group
date where it's like they're all going
around it's almost like a competition of
like
who's been through like the worst thing
and like
it was so it almost like it it
it's devalued it doesn't do justice like
these things that these men have
actually been through and i feel like
ferticia
i don't know who made it this way but i
feel like fertilization like that is so
much for one woman to have on her
shoulders all of these men who are vying
for her
and now they've all completely opened
themselves up in front of each other
that's why she was crying that's why she
was crying
it's too heavy no i couldn't agree more
i thought the setting was like just
wholly inappropriate like like let's
just talk about like the actual
like um physical like everyone's
standing
in a square holding frames like it was
just
not ideal physical setting then i don't
know you want to open
up about your trauma like in front of 20
relative strangers like yeah
and then also think about the cameraman
the producers like there's just so many
people
and the whole thing gave me a weird vibe
and and i thought what everyone opened
up about was like
really lovely and i don't want to be
really personal and it's i'm
not saying anything bad about that
because i think like any person let
alone like a man who opens up like it's
it's hard and i just like it just didn't
make me feel the way i think it was
intended to make me feel yeah and i
think it's a lot of pressure for tasha
to like have
to specifically all of that information
to all of these guys like in front of
each one of them
it's just a lot like it was like a
firing started as like a nude
like a junkie nude painting
yeah i agree but i think there were some
people who did like a really cute and i
think it started out light and then it
just got super heavy yeah brandon with
his frame where he put himself in the
portrait and then i turned it to the
side like that was
perfect ivan with the puzzle piece like
king ivan he's definitely top four
material
um and and i can't stress this enough
because i don't want people to like give
me [ __ ]
i'm not saying anything and you know who
i think handled it well
ben because naked ben because when he
got naked i'm like this is bizarre and
kind of weird but oh but then he told
her privately
and it followed up and it made sense
like oh him showing off his body is like
a really big deal
and he told her privately like i don't
know to me like that made more sense
right and i'm not necessarily judging
the men for
for sharing i just don't know what like
circumstances led to
okay we're all gonna like you know open
up
today i just i just thought it was like
it was it was it reminded me of the this
episode of
friends where it's thanksgiving and
everyone is like it's just like
all these like lies are coming to truth
and
and ross ross says this thing and that's
reminding us he's like it's thanksgiving
not
truth day and like that's what it felt
like everyone was just like telling
their truth
it's naked art not true when it felt so
random because
they were just doing an art class and
obviously like production told them to
do this and like that's just what i
didn't agree with like production like
i don't know i felt like exploiting
people's trauma i totally agree
and and i can't stress this enough i'm
not saying
what any of the guys did was wrong i
just felt like the whole setting was
very
strange i totally agree that's how i
feel also um and then we spent like the
last 20 minutes of the episode like oh
there was one more one on one
and he got sent home yeah that was and
that was so strange that was very very
strange but i did think it was kind of
weird of him to say that he was falling
in love with her but he's literally
never speaking
you either think it's going to be the
thing that keeps you here
till the end or it gets you sent home if
you stay one minute
too early yeah and yeah by the way like
i don't even think i've ever seen tasha
and easy talk so like he's obviously not
in love with her like
i just think he's seen one too many
episodes of the bachelor and like knows
that that's a step you have to take and
want it to be like ahead of the curve
but not on your first one-on-one no but
i was having so much fun on the
one-on-one until that moment because it
was
so funny like um the haunted house like
i just thought it was hilarious like
t-shirts so funny easy so funny
i actually think they might have been
like really compatible but i just don't
think easy was being
and i'd like to easy a lot i just don't
think he was coming off like at all like
authentic do you know what he means yeah
and i think she has like a good radar
for that yeah and i do think like
if if he hadn't said i'm falling in love
with you like he
probably would have gotten the rose but
like you're not even if you really
really like her like you're not falling
in love with her yet your date was like
a fun silly thing that's not
like falling in love yet you guys have
yet to even like open yourselves up to
each other
yeah 100 so i i saw by she sent him
i thought it was just like surprising
and i actually really like when
bachelorettes send guys home like in the
middle of
dates not to embarrass them or anything
but just to not waste their time
and so while i appreciated that like i
was just surprised because i think
easy's such a catch
yeah and he's been like probably one of
my favorites like since the beginning
yeah even with claire no and they
literally flash to the guys in the house
being like they probably have the
strongest connection like there's no way
he's going home
yeah and so i thought they were setting
us up when they were showing to the guys
all saying that
i thought they were setting us up for
like easy going really far because i
hadn't thought that they had like an
immediate obvious connection but the
guys obviously in the house see
something that we don't see
yeah but they're obviously just setting
us up to trick us like right like no
that's
i you should have known when that
happened but there's no way he's going
home yeah
yeah i'm home um and then
i don't even like the noah and bennett
stuff is so dumb but tasha looked
fire as [ __ ] when she walked into that
room stunning that dress
she's really i know they have the same
stylus for every batch run for every
season but
he like just i think he's just really
connecting with tasha and her body
because he's dressing her like just
so well so while i was actually thinking
like if if the turnaround was so
quick for her to become the bachelorette
like how did they get all of these like
sickening styles for her i'm sure they
like mass ordered
from revolve and and by the way i'm sure
tasha and claire are similar sizes
oh yeah like they could wear the same
yeah no but this and then
i'm sure they've seen this green dress
she wore to dinner with easy i was like
with the chain sleeves was so sweet and
well
she just looks amazing like at every
turn i sh
not to obviously pit anyone against each
other but like she's
like so [ __ ] stunningly beautiful
like i just i can't she's a pleasure to
watch on television i completely agree
like just a true
looks are completely on point and she
looked great even though those wedding
dresses were absolutely heinous like
each one she came out in was more ugly
than the next she carried them all with
grace and elegance
she really did also jojo showed up oh
that's the other thing i want to talk
about like how weird this season is like
so rare we have two bachelorettes in one
season and it just feels like everything
about the season is so flaky like
they're not traveling there's not even
a full bachelorette chris harrison just
ups and leaves for the first time in 15
years like
the whole season just feels so like
stitched together like with a band-aid
you know
also what's like really i can't help but
think about it every single time a new
person shows up even the photographer
for the wedding which was like so
unnecessary they had to quarantine it no
but it's like did they quarantine did
joe
like jojo yes um like ashley i
jared like everyone who came through
they quarantined like the way that they
showed the men
going through it like every single
person who's hopping on did the same
thing
and it's fine if they didn't but they
like were able to confirm that they were
i think they definitely did i don't
think they did like two weeks tested two
weeks tests like
i do i don't i really do because think
about when this was filmed now i feel
like things are a little bit more
relaxed
um but this was filmed like four months
ago like when things were worse
right but i just think like they had
these people who were coming like get
tested and then they were able to come
or maybe like ashley and jared like live
in l.a and like they just had to stay in
their apartment for two weeks
maybe i don't know no it's like joking
about dallas yeah no
jojo's a big question like i just it
just makes me like annoyed that we had
to watch all that stuff in the beginning
when it's like you guys have
clearly figured out a way to get like a
photographer in for the afternoon
yeah the photographer um i just feel
like they really did him dirty like
i'm sure the pictures came out much
better and they were just like they kept
freeze framing i'm like
they weren't even smiling like it was
just like that whole scene was edited
very strangely it was so
so bad like it would have been nice to
see some of the cute photos but like we
couldn't yeah
no i thought it was really cute like the
whole thing and i just couldn't believe
he was married again like and i did like
all the different styles of wedding they
had like princess wedding
vegas rock star wedding oh by the way do
you think that it's at all a coincidence
that there are now two guys who have
been
married um who were on claire's season
what do you mean like they knew taisha
was coming and they
loaded up with guys who have been
married previously
no i don't i just think some of them
happen to be older because claire was oh
that's true
and so if you're 35 like you're more
likely married before
are stronger that's such a brilliant
point you're a genius um
so that's our bachelorette recap
anything else we missed from the episode
it was just it wasn't it wasn't anything
to write home about
no but like i do feel like there have
been a few moments this season where i'm
like actually shocked which literally
happens or i'm like hysterically
laughing yes which rarely happens
a hundred percent yeah um all right so
that's our bachelorette recap and now
we're gonna dive into deer toasters our
advice segmentation they were quiet
today
yeah but they don't forget about them
like they're here and
they're proud yeah um but thanks for
being quiet it's so annoying
um our advice segment is brought to you
by athletic
greens with so many stressors in life
it's difficult to maintain effective
nutritional habits and give our bodies
the nutrients it needs to thrive
busy schedules poor sleep exercise
stress or simply not eating enough of
the right foods
this is where athletic greens can help
their daily all-in-one superfood powder
is by far the easiest and most delicious
nutritional habit that you can add to
your health routine today
and empower you to take ownership of
your health one tasty scoop of athletic
greens contains 75 vitamins minerals and
whole foods
whole food source ingredients including
multivitamin multi mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more
they all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet increase
energy and focus aid
with digestion and support a healthy
immune system all without the need to
take multiple products
they continue to obsessively improve
their formula based on the latest
research
in producing 53 iterations over the last
decade and counting
and athletic greens is doubling down on
supporting your immune system during the
winter months they are offering our
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit our link
today
you'll basically never have to buy
vitamins again and by the way i've been
taking vitamin d now
um from athletic greens for like the
last month i would say
because um they say like with kovid like
you should be taking it for your
immunity
so to get a free year supply in this day
and age is just a bargain that you
really can't
put a price on um visit
athleticgreens.com
toast that's athleticgreens.com
toast to get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five
free travel packs today again that link
is at athleticgreens.com
toast and you can only get the free year
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs if you use that link
athleticgreens.com
toast love it all right dear toasters
our advice segment if you ever want to
write in the email is dear toasters
gmail.com we'll always keep it anonymous
and you can write in about anything
okay let's go dear jackie claudia my
boyfriend and i have been living
together for about eight months now
i've been supporting us financially as i
have been back at work since may and he
just returned a few weeks ago
one girl i work with told me she has an
only fans account and made about forty
thousand dollars in the last month
i've been super stressed about money and
thought i have a nice ass why not make a
few extra dollars
i created an only fans account behind
his back because even talking about
money stresses him out
i only had the account active for four
days and felt so guilty so i deleted it
a few days later my boyfriend confronted
me about my about the situation and we
talked about why i started one
he had a few questions but understood
why i did it
since our conversation about the account
i've not stopped wondering about how he
found out about the account it was only
active for four days and i
only had one fan only fan lol she said
i always used to i always used a private
browser when accessing the account and
would delete the window after
sketchy i know i've talked about it with
a few friends and they think he either
went through my phone or
some sort oh some sort of spyware on my
phone should i bring it up to my
boyfriend i feel guilty because i know
i'm in the wrong for creating the
account
but really want to know how he found out
also what should i do if he did go
through my phone or
has spyware sincerely a toaster who only
posted a few butt picks for a buck
um that's a good question like i guess i
would be fixated too on how we found out
and you 100 have to ask
i don't know because if he has spyware
and like i feel like we always see this
in movies like when you're suspicious of
something so you go to the person and
like
let them know of your suspicions and
then you very like you lose your
advantage yeah of
being suspicious so i would try like
maybe
like now that we're like there's spyware
involved like we have to be surprised
about it
right and it's not like your average
like just ask your boyfriend if he went
through your phone cause if he went
through your phone
that's one thing but if you're
suspicious of spyware then we've got to
be
spotted no no we need to level up we
have to call in the big guns juni cortez
you need to
like do something on your phone that
would make him ask you a question
do you know what i mean huh like just
like you were on only fans which made
him ask why are you on only fans
yeah like start looking at like bbw like
something you know
yeah like something that'll alert him
that would alert him that would make him
ask you a question that's a
very good plan you know what i mean so i
don't know what it is for him like if
i'm
selling feet pics or something yes yes
because that'll
because that's in line with only fans
like oh she's just trying to make my
extra money
is having spyware on someone's phone
like in a casual way
yeah illegal no is it a thing yeah i
don't know you guys your friends sound
like they're gasps i didn't even like
making you really paranoid but i
i i think your initial
curiosity about how he found out is very
valid yeah i would
probably as far as like a full-blown you
know mole in your phone
but i do if he's going through your
stuff you got to know yeah i've never
heard of like casual spyware that's like
if you're not in the cia like you have
like spies in your phone no like i think
but i also i'm like not
you know up on some stuff i got i
haven't read my spy monthly
so i'm not entirely sure but um
i i agree like i think you might be like
over thinking like he might just be like
looking through your phone when you're
in the shower you know like there's no
sophisticated technology does he have
your password like his sad possibility
yeah i would love a follow-up here to be
honest um but i think that you should
definitely
do some digging on how he found out it
says and lay some traps like just like
casual traps
yeah like pretend you're having an
affair like with this random number you
know
yeah like get some texts going like make
it one of your friends like change
remove no delete her um delete her
contacts so
people who are shady don't save cell
phone numbers that's always how you know
they're being shady
oh interesting so yeah do something like
that and like have a fake affair and lay
a trap and destroy your relationship
uh yeah that's our advice next like but
just do a little spy work
if you think they're spies you know
don't go to him with your suspicions
like
it's it's if you have to one-up the spy
yeah because if there's spyware going on
like this is nefarious you don't go
to like the person who's being nefarious
and say are you a nefarious person
yeah but i guess in like the name of
honesty like in a relationship like
that's actually what you should do
right but he broke the honor code first
if he is a spy
yeah but do you think there's any way
that like one of your friends like was a
snitch
yeah because you didn't say that you
didn't tell me you could lay traps there
too so you're go tell each fan a
different secret tell one you're going
back on only fans
tell another you weren't about the picks
but but you're gonna sell feed picks
like tyrion lannister and game of
thrones tell everyone something
different
and whichever one gets back to him
snitch alert yeah like tyrion lannister
or like kardashians when they thought
jonathan chaybon was selling stories so
they like made up fake stories to
jonathan
yeah um we hope that was helpful i think
that was
next up hey claude jacks thanks for
being my source of news and
entertainment over the year 2020.
now let's get to the not so good stuff
i've been dating slash engaged to an
actual p-john
literally puts up with my sassy ass and
i don't know why sometimes we've been
together for over a year and have plans
to get married next spring
the past summer my high school ex added
me on snapchat he would randomly message
me and i would sometimes respond
the past couple weeks we have snapped
each other every day all day and even
late at night
at one point we had what the kids called
a streak going
i know i know stupid we are three we are
30 and too old to care
he is married with one child and another
one on the way our conversa convos are
mostly light
but sometimes get flirty and sexual but
never in a sexting way
or towards each other that it's more
like that's what she said stuff you know
like silly jokes
i know i shouldn't be talking to him but
i'm so stressed with working full time
outside of the home in this cobbed
climate
wedding planning house buying throwing
money out left and right so having this
fun outside distraction has been nice am
i a horrible person how and when should
i end this little affair
thanks for your solicited advice okay
i'm gonna do my absolute best like not
to be judgey but like you
have to stop like i hate when people do
this like ruin perfectly good things
like
not only do you have something really
good going on he has something really
good going on like what are you guys
doing like
i i realize that you're stressed play
tennis like
don't go making like snapchat affairs
like i am so not here for this
you are making a mistake and your man is
a p john and you have to fix it and you
have to stop and so does he
you're making a mistake and you should
stop right now delete the snapchat app
before you make a real mistake like this
is just
i understand that right now like you can
make the argument that like you guys are
just technically friends can boys and
can x's be friends and snap like
sure sure but what's the point really
and then so you're saying it's like a
fun little distraction
find a different distraction no there's
just so many things like i've taken up
knitting i watch a lot of tv
become a redhead there's so many yeah
there's so many become a patreon member
like there's so many things that you
could do to distract yourself
um i just this is like
i feel like this is like a plot of a
movie you know like there's nothing like
i just i've seen this before somewhere
and i just know it doesn't end well and
like i really encourage you just like
stop
and you're saying that your man is a p
john like we have to protect pee jobs at
all costs
that's all when she said that like that
was the nail in the coffin for me where
i was like
and then he also has a baby like there's
no there's no you know
it's not like a love affair that it's
like we're gonna be together you guys
aren't otp
no not at all oh my god your otp is
waiting at home for you go back in bed
yeah yeah i'm i'm sorry to ruin the fun
i know to be a fun ruiner but you wrote
into us knowing
that the fun needed to be ruined
sometimes you know where you need to
hear the hard truth and that's what
we're giving you today sorry
i'm so sorry it's gonna be like focus on
p john
focus on the p john next up hi claudia
and jackie and of course doctor for
chapman hi doctor for champion she's
both for chairman wrong but she said i'm
sorry i'm a horrible speller
i'm writing in desperate need of help in
regards to my brother's horrible
girlfriend she's an absolute terror i'm
talking rude to my family rude to my
parents friends and doesn't try to be
kind to my mom and me
anyways they've been dating for about
eight months now and my brother knows we
hate her and is gonna date her in spite
of us
i really thought she was gonna be gone
by now but the holidays are approaching
and she's planning on spending all the
holidays with my family
thanksgiving is fine because of covey
we're not supposed to travel but she
doesn't plan on going home for christmas
my family is extremely close and my mom
and i are not comfortable with this
we feel like we are walking on eggshells
around him and her and we can't even
tell him it's weird
she doesn't want to see go see her own
family it's not hard for her to go home
it's only a couple hours drive so they
think it's weird that like she won't go
home and see her on family
anyways what do i do i do not want my
christmas to be spent with her and it
truly gives me anxiety thinking i might
have to deal with her forever
p.s my brother once sent a nude of her
in our family group chat and never told
her
seems like the smoking gun but i'm not
going to be the sister but how [ __ ]
hilarious and disturbing is that my mom
said it's the last thing i ever wanted
to see but i now get why he likes her
that's funny oh man this is a horrible
situation because i feel like one of two
ways like
part of me is like if your brother is
really like a spite dater the fact that
you guys are also up in arms about it
like you're giving him more energy to
like keep going and like making you
angry
so part of me wants to be like just
pretend like you don't care and like
maybe he'll get realize he doesn't even
like her and there's nothing there
but then you run the risk of like him
thinking that all is good and like
marrying her
you know yeah i'm gonna play devil's
advocate here
i think rude is a subjective term and
you haven't given
us really like real concrete reasons as
to why you don't like her
now you say eight months why should come
in a family christmas
you know they're not like at that level
yet you complain that she's rude to your
parents friends
why and how is she around your parents
friends in the last eight months if like
they're not that serious and also it's a
pandemic wow nancy you're over here
maybe like they are more serious than
you think and again i would like to
understand like what she has done that
is rude you know
because maybe she's a [ __ ] and like i'm
totally off base and
you know you could we're just taking you
because this girl wrote us in
we're just taking you could give me a
laundry list of things that she's done
but maybe we come at it from her side he
has this
family of strong-willed women and maybe
she's a little shy
and the shyness comes off as rudeness i
know for me sometimes that has happened
my shyness does come off as rudeness
because you'll expect me to be like
big and bubbly and then when i'm kind of
quiet they're like oh she's just not
talking to
us yes by the way a lot of people think
that you're rude when you meet them
yeah because i'm just like kind of quiet
and reserved and they think i'm just
like
being judgmental but i'm just like being
i'm i'm shy like i'm feeling
uncomfortable and i think people think
like just because your hair is red like
you would be like loud in the center of
attention when it's
you're actually the opposite no 100 so
my advice to is going to be a little
different okay let's see christmas out
of the equation sounds like she's coming
i think you and her should have a night
together maybe get a little drunk
maybe get to know her a little bit and
try and understand
like why she is the way she is maybe at
the end of it she's
she's the [ __ ] you thought she was but
you you at least tried yeah
i just think especially if you know
there
and also if your brother is really a
spike dater and he sees her you're like
trying to get to know her
he might rethink his strategy but also
sometimes at the end of the day i think
some of the like the best friendships
always start with two girls who hated
each other
100 olivia and danny yeah like lifelong
friends for life and hated each other so
much
yeah i think you guys like when she's at
i don't know what your plans are but
when she's
you guys are together for the holidays
you guys like have a girls night get a
little drunk
share your secrets well don't give her
too much because if she's really mean
you use it against you
but you know just like kick back no like
you could hate someone so much like you
have a couple drinks and like you are
their best friend it's actually
crazy like and like you guys might bond
in a way that like you might understand
her better you might not be best friends
but like
you might have a different opinion of
her you know what you really opened my
eyes jackie i agree with you
i'm just it tis the season you know
spread love and joy
deck the halls with boughs of theo
fa la la la la la la la la la
that was your toasters hour by segment
again if you ever want to write in or if
you have written it in the last few
months and we read your advice on air
and you have an update for us please
send an update to deartoasters gmail.com
just put update in the subject line we
really want to hear from you guys
um but thank you to everyone who wrote
in today and we hope that was helpful i
actually think that might have been
some of our best advice yet i totally
agree except for the spy stuff if only
we were spy kids
don't forget to pre-order my book growth
in a job.com
book it is my autobiographical memoir
comedy it's honestly comedy at its
finest jackie's read it
and she's a really harsh critic and even
if she hated it i think she would tell
me so
if i would hated it i would have like
given you like it was still in the
writing phase i would have given you
like right
no some more criticism so check it out
girls on job.com
book anything you want before we go new
episode of the redhead shops next week
follow me on instagram jackyo problems
follow the pups with no job instagram if
you're looking for some content uppers
i posted a photo yesterday that is my
new go-to content upper where it just
like
will always bring a smile to my face
it's of theo and magnolia being the
cutest cousins i'm working on a version
where
theo is photoshopped in because they're
just the cutest cousins that anyone has
ever seen
pups with no job premium content between
the three of them like the premium
content
it's on a daily basis now and i don't
think you'll regret it thank you guys so
much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we hit
70 000 subscribers that was very
exciting
hey subscribers um we're also available
as a podcast and we're podcasting we
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i already spoke to all the
places wherever you listen to podcast
find us
the morning chose to leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are we hope you have an amazing
day you will see it tomorrow
goodbye